internet trading mob is driving gamestop
chairs higher
this game stock situation is the
craziest i think i've ever seen
what the hell is happening with gamestop
users of reddit's wall street vets forum
have helped bid that stock up
massively this week some will make money
some will lose money but that's just the
way the markets
always work my children are asleep and i
am back here because i need to know what
the hell is happening
with gamestop and the stock market and
short squeezes and all this weird stuff
that is happening
on the internet in the financial markets
so i am going to figure that out right
now
and you are going to learn along with me
i think the first thing i need to do
is buy stock in gamestop what's the
first thing i'm going to do because i
don't fully understand this
but i feel like i need to be a part of
it so i'm gonna buy some shares
and see what happens gamestop short
sellers lost
1.6 billion dollars in a single day as
reddit traders reveled against them so
they decided
we're gonna [ __ ] their whole system up
just to boost games
yes well just to see if they could i'm
deep in it right now
i've been on a call with my my buddy
who's a finance guy
he is walking me through every single
thing
i've also spent an insane amount of time
on investopedia i'm getting this
i am understanding what the hell is
happening here and it is
pretty cool okay here's what happened
to understand this you have to
understand
pokemon cards you don't i mean let me
explain
there's this concept in finance that is
painfully hard to understand for us
laymen outside of the black box of
trading you've heard it a million times
there's a whole movie about it that i
love it's one of my favorite movies of
all time
somebody shorted 200 mil in mortgage
bonds that was just with deutsche
where is he at half the town how much in
total
1.3 billion and yet it's painfully hard
to get your head around but i think i've
done it
and i'm gonna break it down with an
analogy so let's say
it's 2001 and pokemon cards
are a thing but they're not that
valuable yet and you go to your little
brother and you say
let me borrow one of your cards let me
borrow it
i'll borrow it for one year and i
promise i will give it back to you
and your brother's like okay which one
do you want and you're like i want
charizard okay
charizard like a dragon card okay so you
get charizard
i'm not a pokemon guy but i know
charizard you're borrowing
this card from your brother for a year
it's not yours but even still
you're able to go onto ebay and sell it
you sell it for ten dollars
okay so you just sold this charizard
card for ten dollars you just
made ten dollars even though you didn't
spend any money buying that card
but in the back of your mind you know
that you have to give a charizard card
back to your brother you promised you
would
a year goes by and you go back onto ebay
and one of two things will have happened
by then remember you sold it for ten
dollars
but now a year later the card could be
worth two dollars
if it's worth two dollars now because
it's like not that cool anymore
you're pretty excited you buy one off
ebay you go back to your brother and
you're like here here's your charizard
card your brother doesn't care how much
you bought it for
you are making good on the deal by
giving him back his card
you on the other hand are stoked because
you borrowed that card for free
you went and sold it for ten dollars and
then to replace it a year later
it was only two dollars so that eight
dollars is yours
you got that out of nowhere now what
would happen if it went the other way
you go onto ebay a year later to replace
your
brother's charizard card and the price
is now a hundred dollars it's
ten times then you're like oh crap you
had sold it for ten dollars now it's
worth a hundred you have to cough up
ninety dollars of
your own money out of your own pocket to
pay for that to make good on your
promise
to return the card this process
happens every single day right up the
road in new york city where hedge funds
which
are big giant aggregations of money that
are managed by
smart analysts who think about the
economy all day take bets
but instead of pokemon cards you can
borrow someone's stock and go sell it
with the promise that
you will return that stock to them at
some point in the future if you
have a suspicion that charizard cards
are gonna be worth
less money in the future then you'll
probably go to your little brother and
do this deal
it makes a lot of sense you can make
eight bucks if you know that charizard
cards
are gonna be worth a lot less in the
future and this is what hedge funds do
every single day in new york city they
look at companies that they think are
gonna be worth less
in the future and they go to the
shareholders of that company they say
hey let me borrow your stock for a
second i'm gonna go sell it
and i promise i'll give it back to you
in the future let's talk about gamestop
for a second
gamestop is a video game store i
actually went to one
last week because we just got a nintendo
switch like
for the first time we have nintendo in
our home i'm playing zelda with my
children
you ready to play zelda and i needed a
controller so i went to gamestop
the first time i've ever been inside of
one of these places gamestop is a
retailer that is usually in
a mall a place you probably haven't been
in a very long time and especially
during
covet 19. a lot of people up in new york
city who spend their day thinking about
the future of companies in our economy
sort of saw gamestop as
like oh they're doomed like these people
are gonna be out of business
in like no time or in other words oh the
charizard card
that's gonna be worth nothing in a year
i'm gonna go to my little brother and
see if i can
borrow it from him so i can do a deal
and make eight bucks off of this
and if you look at the value of a share
of gamestop
stock during 2020 you would see the omen
this place is doomed it was like down at
four dollars a share sometimes it would
bump up a little bit
this was a cheap stock but again go back
to our little scenario here
it's a year after you borrowed and sold
your brother's charizard pokemon card
for ten dollars you pull up ebay you
search for the card
and now it's worth a hundred dollars or
two hundred dollars
or a thousand dollars and you start to
panic
you have to buy that card and give it to
your brother you have to
where the money comes from that's up to
you this is exactly
what happened a couple of weeks ago look
at the stock it's up more than
680 percent so far this year instead of
this graph going down
this graph went up so now we understand
this concept of shorting a stock that's
that's what it's called
when you think a stock is going to go
down you can take a short position on
that stock
and you can get a payout if it goes down
you smell that what is that what what's
that smell
a cologne no
opportunity no money
but here's where it gets into
unprecedented territory that
gets at the heart of our financial
system and what it even means
the reason this stock went up is because
of a subreddit this subreddit wall
street bets
is full of people who are sort of like
stock bros that like didn't make it to
wall street and decided to become
trolls on the internet it's a bunch of
dudes
misogynistic as hell who are crude
irreverent
and like foul-mouthed but also
incredibly good at trolling the hell out
of hedge funds
these guys caught wind of the fact that
all of these hedge funds
were shorting gamestop that were
basically betting that it was going to
go down
they had borrowed and sold a lot of
charizard cards hoping that it would be
worth a dollar so they decided to rally
around gamestop
and they started buying stock tons of it
all together and when you buy a lot of
stock and there's a lot of demand
the price goes up they realized that all
the institutional investors were hedging
on gamestop
so they just bought a bunch of call
options bought a bunch of stock i'm not
saying they're working in concert i'm
not saying they're doing anything
illegal
i am saying that they are in force soon
this started to catch attention
and people started to see this rally
around gamestop this random like
totally like mediocre retailer
and yet it was rallying in the stock
market and so
more and more people started buying the
stock and the price kept going up
and the hedge funds started to panic
tuesday the the data's a little lagged
was the worst day for this community on
record because here's the thing about
the charizard card you borrowed it from
your brother and you sold it for ten
dollars
if you come back a year later and it's
worth a hundred dollars and you have to
front that ninety dollars somehow to buy
it and return it to your brother
you're panicking if it's worth five
hundred dollars
you're panicking a lot more if it's
worth a thousand dollars
you're panicking a lot more and you can
start to see where this goes
there's no ceiling it can be worth a
thousand
two thousand five thousand a hundred
thousand from ten to a hundred thousand
then what there is no ceiling there is
no end to the amount of losses that you
can take
when you short a position like this they
are being
very specific to break the shorts so
these hedge funds are looking at this
graph just
tick up this stock that was worth
four dollars a share for the majority of
this year
suddenly was worth 40 and then 60 and
then 100 and then 200
and then 300 and 400 and then
it hit an all-time high of 469 dollars
per share
more than a hundred times what it was
during most of 2020.
these hedge funds are dying and
meanwhile the stock bros
on reddit are loving it it's just this
crazy moment
of reddit versus the hedge funds
that i never thought i'd see in my
lifetime and here we are
good evening newly minted reddit
millionaires i'm sure all of you are
watching this from the marble bathtubs
on your hovercraft
so this is one hedge fund in new york in
particular called
melvin capital they are the most screwed
out of everyone
they had borrowed a ton of charizard
cards
and now i had to pay them back so just
like
recently like like last week melvin
capital is in like
deep crisis they're selling off all of
their like
long-term positions i think they've the
things that they want to succeed in the
long run
to like cover this and then they're like
going out and begging for money
and luckily all these hedge fund people
are really connected and they all know
each other and they're all buds
and three billion dollars worth of
capital just comes down from the heavens
like mana
and keeps them afloat barely
so melvin capital's freaking out they
get their three billion dollar
savior fund that comes in and then
today the day i'm filming this it's
friday you're probably watching this on
monday i don't know today
robin hood which is the app that allows
you to trade
really easily and is what probably a lot
of these
uh reddit bros are using to make all
these trades
robin hood freezes trading on gamestop
and several other stocks that were
following in this trend
of like companies that were failing that
a lot of
hedge funds had shorted on and were now
being rallied behind because of freaking
reddit these are called meme stocks
they aren't being rallied because the
company's doing well they're being
rallied
as a sort of fu to hedge funds who have
shorted their position
on these stocks this is unprecedented
for
a trading platform to just halt trading
in the name of what
a lot of people are wondering why did
robin hood stop this isn't this the free
market
well remember melvin capital the hedge
fund that was
most screwed over by this situation
melvin was rescued in the end they
didn't go under
in part with a lot of money from another
fund called
citadel citadel is also a major customer
of robin hood providing up to 35
of their revenue in some years according
to tax forms
i want you to address the obvious this
looks like a move by an outfit called
robin hood which is supposed to be taken
from the rich and giving to the poor
and doing exactly the opposite that when
the big guys including one of your main
investors in your company started to
lose
you shut down the game to starve the
little guy soon you have members of
congress calling for an investigation
this is why we need an sec
that has clear rules about market
manipulation
and take a guess on what you think the
guys on reddit
are gonna do do you think they're gonna
back down and be like oh yeah
robin hood stopped us from trading we're
probably gonna stop doing this
no no no no oh you just poured fuel on
the fire
we don't have all the facts here this is
like fresh and unfolding and
soon we may know but the fact is that
there is a very tight-knit web among all
of these
financial people in new york city that
look out for one another and when a mob
of angry
reddit people show up to completely
screw up their system and their bets
it's not actually that surprising to
think that they would band together
and stop it there will probably be an
investigation into this
and if you're watching this anytime in
the future
beyond the next couple of weeks from
when it was published there will
probably be a lot more information and i
can't wait to get my hands on it
overall this is a crazy thing that is
happening not only because it's like an
amazing spectacle
but because it helps reveal the
craziness
of our financial system i'm not saying
it's bad
i'm saying it's crazy meaning it's
literally mental
it is literally mass psychology how we
value something
and the price we put on it whether it is
a pokemon card
or a share in gamestop
is 100 a result of how
a group of people decide to act towards
it
to think about it that is how our entire
financial system
is modeled value is based on what a
bunch of people
think value is just like a dollar bill
a piece of paper is only valuable
because
we all sort of believe it's valuable we
all take this for granted it's like the
air we breathe
it's become totally status quo to think
of value
and economics and financials in these
terms
and yet a moment like this when it gets
disrupted
when those forces disrupt the status quo
it starts to become a little bit crazy
to think of it in these terms it almost
takes the curtain away a little bit and
shows us what our financial system
really is built off of
which is mass psychology so i bought
some shares of gamestop
and whether it
wins or loses in the next few days
i'm just excited to be a part of this
ride this is
crazy all right that's it
there's no sponsor for today's video
because i just made it really quickly i
guess i'll just make a plug for my
patreon go follow me on patreon help
support my videos okay bye